our next question is from Tyler hi guys
my name is Tyler and I'm a patreon
subscriber from Ann Arbor Michigan I had
a pretty simple question for yall have
you ever had one object or thing or
person experience that took the place of
many other things um this question came
in mind as I bought a new pair of
minimalist training shoes that replace
like three other shoes in my wardrobe
that just didn't provide as much value
um thanks for everything bye Leo
something you helped me realize really
early on when I was still simplifying
was the purpose of a thing is to be used
or enjoyed it's not for status it's not
to get other people to like me it's um
it it is enhancing my life in some way
amplifying my pre-existing Joy or
happiness or whatever it might be it
doesn't create happiness but sometimes
the things that I have are like tools in
my life and it's okay to it's
appropriate to have multi-purpose tools
as well I think of a smartphone as a
multi-purpose tool and that can be
really useful until it's not it can also
really get in the way sometimes the
multi-purpose things are a bit
cumbersome and it makes sense to even
simplify those but to answer Tyler's
question headon yeah quite often if you
buy a really great pair of shoes that
you enjoy it might replace all of the
Absurd shoes that you had for all of
these different occasions and I notic
Leo with with your clothing you wrote
about that quite a bit on Zen habits
early on um a lot of your clothing was
sort of multipurpose so I have a pair of
pants that will work here it'll work for
my walks it'll work for the gym and I
realized like oh yeah I don't have to
have seven different things when one
thing can replace all of them can you
talk a bit about that sure I was I was
racking my brain actually to come up
with an answer to that question I'm like
what do I have that actually like
replaces many things uh but clothing is
a good example yeah I I don't have a lot
of clothing um I wear the same stuff
every day like a few t-shirts and I
think one pair of pants now uh and I'll
wear this for travel I'll wear it for
speaking I'll wear it around the house
um in general I also have like workout
clothes and I wear those a lot um but
yeah so I I for me I it's hard for me to
remember what it was like before I I did
all of that so but I did have a lot more
clothing and I had to have
you know clothes for this purpose and
this purpose and this purpose and I'm
like no I'm just going to wear the same
thing to everything no one cares what I
wear you know um I'm not the you know
I'm not there for fashion you know and
so people are just like okay that's just
who he is um the one answer I did come
up with was a phone actually I I had um
used to have a bunch of books I've
gotten rid of a bunch of books then I
replaced it with a Kindle and then now I
just I got rid of the kind Kindle and
I'm just using the phone U because I
already carry that around anywhere I am
I just have the books right there in my
phone and um so I that's that's what I
use for for books but I also use it I
don't use notebooks anymore I use it for
notes I use it for writing sometimes um
when I'm out and uh so there's there's
just like a lot of apps that I use now
that replace a whole bunch of like
physical things that I used to have I
love like physical notebooks but I was
like not really I'm not bringing it
everywhere and I don't really I don't
I'm they're like half filled and and I
don't not using it that much and so I'm
like the phone's just always with me um
that's not that revolutionary an answer
but that's the one answer that I did
come up with no but I think it's helpful
also to look at the other side for some
people just getting rid of the notebook
and the calendar or whatever for some
people those things are more useful than
the phone because the phone can be a
distract
right but for you it sounds like the
phone isn't a distraction why is that uh
I don't have a bunch of notifications
and I don't um yeah I don't have like
social media and stuff like that on
there uh
so um yeah the phone is for me just a
tool for you making stuff and reading
and all of that kind of stuff I uh there
have been times when I get hooked on
something like Reddit was something I
was hooked on when I was really
interested in like a couple of topics so
for that I was like I was on Reddit all
the time and then I'm like okay
uninstall Reddit this is not like how I
want to live my life so like now you
know it's not that I don't ever look at
social media or email or messages or
anything like that but um I don't find
the phone to be um terribly distracting
I guess it's just like how you relate to
the phone absolutely and and what you
just said there I had to write it down
because what a profound St simple
statement and yet really profound
especially if we say it out loud if I'm
doing something that I don't want to do
simply saying aloud just to myself but
this is not how I want to live my
life and maybe even rephrasing it as a
question I'm scrolling Tik Tock for 45
minutes is this how I want to live my
life and if the answer to that is yes
great no judgment but you're being
honest with yourself at that point but
what we often do is we consume
mindlessly this isn't how I want to live
my life but I'm this is how I am living
my life because I never stopped to
consider is this how I want to live my
life I really really love this theme and
I'm going to have to spend some time
later just kind of digging into this of
the one thing by which many things are
obtained and I think about it in terms
of like my own health journey and having
to make a lot of eating changes and just
no longer being able to physically you
know uh digest things that I used to eat
a lot of comfort foods and what I find
is that a lot of the things that are
healthier for me though they take a lot
of initial discipline to eat they tend
to be more satiating than a lot of the
other things I would eat so when I'm
eating a bunch of snack foods the things
I can get at a gas station I need to be
eating all the time because although it
tastes good it doesn't nourish me and so
I need a whole lot of it and I'm hungry
all the time eating all the time and
then it's like hey you know I get myself
nice juicy steak it's like I can go for
hours without anything right and so
there are things in life that there're
so lacking in substance they're so
superficial that we get addicted to them
not because there's something wrong with
us but because we're trying to meet a
real substantial important need through
things that are just not optimized for
what our soul really Longs for and and
so where this plays a major role for me
is with social media deut declutter
knowledge declutter we're in an age of
information anxiety man where it's like
every single day there are thousands of
videos being produced on a single topic
I I I heard someone say something to the
effect of like even just like 100 years
ago being a polymath was possible you
could read like three books on each
field and be a polymath whereas now
anything that you want to know about
sorry there were a thousand YouTube
videos produced on that yesterday good
luck just catching up on that right and
so you feel like you got to know a bunch
of stuff and Professor sea and I were
talking about this with his YouTube
Habits where sometimes just reading one
good book is worth a billion tweets
sometimes just reading one primary
source on a topic that you're interested
in or one textbook or one classic
written by somebody that's not alive
today on anything from psychology to
economics can be worth a thousand
podcast episodes of people debating
about that or take it with relationships
one person telling you I really
appreciate you or sitting across from
you in a coffee shop discussing a
difference they have with you can be
more valuable than 20 million people
liking that tweet or 20 trolls 20 dis
ideological opponents arguing with you
online and so we're so obsessed with
keeping up and having so many
conversations and part of that may be
because we're not having real
relationships real interactions real
conversations reading real books and
exploring things of substance and that's
kind of been my one thing that I use to
obtain many I love
that I um I was thinking about going
back to the um the question of social
media on the phone uh I what I realized
after I gave my answer to that was that
um there's a need that you you kind of
spoke to that the need that drives us to
want to like look at our phone for
social media or Tik Tok or looking at um
you know just basic basally distracting
ourselves and so what I realize is that
the uh that's that need we're hoping to
fulfill through the through the phone uh
another way to look at it is like
there's a um stress or anxiety that
we're having that we think that their
phone will
relieve so like I'm feeling stressed
right now and I'm GNA get on my phone to
like you know relieve myself of that
stress like distract myself give myself
a little bit of
downtime and you know what if you really
pay attention to that stress it actually
goes up as you engage with these things
like ah this thing that I thought was
going to like you know now I'm behind on
everything else that I was supposed to
do now I'm like like more like I'm
busier and I'm like frantically like
scrolling and uh it just like
accelerates the feeling and so um I what
I realiz is the reason why the phone
isn't as big of a pull for me it's you
know it has some things I I do work
stuff on my phone too um so it has some
pull to for me but it's not as big a
pull for me anymore is that like I I
address the stress directly I just
notice like oh what's having me reach
for my phone oh I'm feeling like some
overwhelm right now I'm feeling some
anxiety about something that's coming up
so I'm like actually before this podcast
I was feeling a bit of nerves coming
into this podcast so I was like on my
phone and I'm like huh I think I'm
feeling some nerves so I just sat with
with the the feeling that came up that's
just like uncertainty about what might
happen you know it's fascinating it's
almost like taking
painkillers that increase your pain in a
way that actually is what happens you
know I'm from Dayton Ohio it's the
overdose capital of America people get
stuck on opioids right because they take
them to relieve a pain but it ends up
causing so much more pain in their lives
and I think the same is is true not with
the phone itself the phone isn't
inherently bad just like opioids aren't
inherently bad they have a purpose but
when we reach to it anytime we feel a
bit of discomfort or boredom or anxiety
or stress or overwhelm it actually ends
up amplifying the emotions we sought the
phone out to eliminate in the first
place and so realizing that whatever
emotion I'm feeling right now the phone
is probably going to amplify that and
it's certainly not going to to
extinguish my anxiety I hope you enjoyed
that highlight from the minimalist
private podcast if You' like another
highlight check out this video if you'd
like to watch the minimal episode check
out this video or if you'd like to dive
deep into full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast head on over
to patreon the link is in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube channel 100%
advertisement free